programming throwdown episode 83 teaching kids to code take it away jason hey everybody so uh something pretty interesting happened i knocked over a bottle of coke and coke went absolutely everywhere. This was about a week ago. Completely ruined my keyboard that I bought a long long time ago. And so I went on Amazon and I found out the keyboards are way cheaper now. I bought a mechanical keyboard actually I don't know like I bought a mechanical keyboard way back, but either I just forgot or I wasn't paying attention But basically there's there's colors for the switches and the color doesn't just mean because the first was like cherry red and the keyboards
Black it didn't make any sense, but basically The colors correspond to how the key feels so if you have cherry red that's the softest setting basically the softer the keyboard is kind of at least in my opinion the better it feels but the less you're sort of let's say guaranteed to press the button so you know if it's really hard and it makes a big kind of click sound like i think the blue mechanical switch does this it makes a big kind of click sound when you press that to me is kind of annoying but at least it's like you know that you press that key like there's no in between um so i chose i think there's brown which is in the middle i chose cherry red um and i love it i think it's great i mean i i
haven't had an issue actually it took a little bit of getting used to so you know in the beginning like sometimes i wouldn't totally hit the key but at this point now like you know i i haven't had any issues and i like the way it feels and so it's a lot cheaper so um so that's kind of what i'm what i'm typing on right now so i didn't know for a long time about i guess they're called mechanical keyboards i thought you know all mechanic all keyboards are mechanical but apparently i was wrong as always um so most keyboards that aren't last time ever on the show most most keyboards not like laptop keyboards but desktop keyboards are i guess they call like membrane switches or rubber domes so it's like a piece of rubber where the bottom of your key has a bit of metal
and the pcb underneath has a bit of metal and when you push down your key the two pieces of metal touch and that's what makes the click and so they're kind of mushy uh yeah but the reason why they're not touching all the time is just you have this piece of rubber and so when you're pushing you're squishing the rubber yeah and i never knew any different and in fact i don't think most people do until you go try one of these quote-unquote mechanical keyboards where there's springs and plastic levers and whether or not there's clicking detents or just tactile bump detents and as jason said there's like six or seven different colors and there's even a community where people open up the switches and change out the springs so like you can just the
weight of the key on your reds you could make it heavier but you really like the reds the slidiness of it and so you could change it to be slightly stiffer or slightly looser in addition to buying a different color to like get it even more customized. And then you can buy like lubricant to sprinkle down in the key so that the keys slide differently. People mod like take the reds stem it's called and the blues clicker or something. I don't know what combinations make sense and just really mod it up so you can take it to the extreme. And then you can also with the mechanical keyboards, it tends to be that you can change your key caps so i didn't know about this either but like my keyboard the cap actually won't come off the key and so the the thing that has the writing on it the letter or the number is
attached to the keyboard you can't pull it off but on the fancier ones you can and you can buy replacement ones of varying crazy colors and there's even like uh people probably notice i guess but there's like artistic key caps where you can get like little sculpted superheroes or figure eights rubik's cubes whatever i guess uh kinds of things you want and they can become very expensive like 7500 150 dollars per key per letter what no way yeah yeah yeah like it's like an art collecting like collectible things um oh my gosh but then in addition you can buy 100 and 107 keys or something well so that's the other thing is you can buy key sizes down from 40 percent keyboards which
is approximately 40 keys to 60 percent to the normal like i think it's 110 keys is roughly a full-size keyboard or 10 keyless which is you drop the numpad stuff off to the right and you end up with about 70 or 80 keys or something okay that makes sense yeah yeah the sky's the limit some people who are really crazy built their own keyboard so this is the rabbit hole i went down so i wanted a split keyboard so i want a keyboard where the left and right hand you can adjust them so people make fun of me at work uh because i don't have like a super weird keyboard by normal standards but it's split so i have it kind of far apart sometimes like as much as like a foot apart and then like when i eat lunch for instance i have
my food in the middle and the keyboard on either side of my food um like on both sides and so so that's what i really like and it prevents you from cheating like your right finger can't type on the left side because it's really far away um oh that makes sense yeah so then i learned about this thing called the dactyl keyboard d-a-c-t-y-l uh which turns out is like a 3d printed case for you to mount these mechanical switches in that you can just buy off the internet. And then you hand wire the switches together with diodes and into a microcontroller. In this case, I used a variant of an Arduino,
a very small Arduino, and you put one in each half. And then the left half talks to the right half over serial across a headphone cable ahead like a 3.5 millimeter cable and then you plug the usb cable into the one on the right and it acts as a usb device to make your letters wait why why would you use a headphone cable and not uh like something easier to program like like i don't know ethernet or something well well so the headphone cable connects the two halves because it turns out your computer gets confused if you have two keyboards plugged in
like it doesn't work well so you only plug one computer sorry go ahead you have to write your own protocol to get well so there's an open source project that's pretty popular with diy keyboard people called qmk um that that people use to do most of this programming. And then you specify a key map because the keyboard doesn't know what the letters are. And you can literally arrange them in, not infinite, but very large variety of key combinations. And so you tell it which key corresponds to what letter. So you can do things like Colmac or Dvorak keyboards
in addition to the normal QWERTY keys. You can also adjust what the thumb, on this one there's thumb clusters so the letters your thumb can type and like space and backspace are like on opposite sides on your thumbs another popular one is the ergo docks is a keyboard that's similar to this uh anyway so there's like a the amount of customization goes through the roof um and it's actually a pretty big learning curve because there's also layers. So you can sort of have a button that you push and all of the keys become that they do something else. And the whole keyboard, you sort of raise up a layer or lower a layer. And then you have modifiers.
So like there's no arrow keys. So you might raise up a layer and then your arrow keys are on the, you know, WASD or I don't know, UHJK. You just make it whatever you want. And so the amount of customization goes up and you have to get kind of used to it. So I built one of these and was using it for a while, but I couldn't get over the learning curve.
So now it sits unused. But interestingly enough, there's, if you look this up the guy who made it made a video and if you're into 3d printing which we talked about a while there's a thing called open scad which is a way to generate the stl which is sort of the the water type mesh the triangles that you feed to a 3d printer to 3D print an object. You can describe that from primitives. Sort of like if you've ever used, what was the name of it?
One of some of the POV ray, was it? One of the ray tracers where you sort of describe a scene. It's very much like that. And sort of this very simple programming language. So he didn't like that. So what he did was write in Clojure a way to generate OpenSCAD, which then you run to generate the STLs and then you print. So you can actually like add rows or columns to the keyboard and the keyboard a bunch of like uh key tops or keys i guess key caps yeah and then you bought the uh mechanical switches yes and you soldered it all together yes with
like wires and so is this what you use every day no so i couldn't get over the learning curve of it it was too it was too custom oh i see but but if you had made uh one that was uh like so what was hard about it so i don't know if you look at the pictures so for this one it's that the things you would normally do kind of like with your pinkies like the backspace delete or whatever and then it has like become on your thumbs so like the shifts aren't with your pinkies they become with your thumbs yeah so for people who like are listening to this which is almost everybody basically like imagine imagine you know if you took a keyboard and you kind of you kind of broke it into into like four pieces and there's there's a piece for each of your um what's the word for this um there's okay there's a piece for each of your opposable thumbs
that's two pieces and then there's a piece for each of your the rest of your of each of your hands what's left over so you have these four pieces and you have these like you know two kind of little squares for your opposable thumbs that kind of hang on to the other to the rest of the to the to either side of the keyboard yeah and i could imagine it's really hard to get used to yeah so my friend has one of the ergo docs which is the same thing as this but basically like pushed down flat so without the curviness so if you took this whole thing like flattened it down and that was pretty popular um he has that one and it took him probably like two solid weeks and he was a much better typist than i am i'm a terrible typist actually um is that the right word for that oh well and so he got terrible time it's got good
alliteration there we go terrifically terrible typist patrick was typing terrifically terribly one day um and that sounds like a typing test oh that's right so it's like flan and it's called the ergo doc so he got one of these keyboards his was pre-made um but you know he learned to type on it and took him solid like two weeks to even become like passable at it and then he was telling me the other day he's like yeah i think i kind of just want to go back to using a normal keyboard like it's it's he still feels like he doesn't uh he is not as comfortable to him like Like he still occasionally makes mistakes. So I think it's one of those things that either jives with you or it doesn't.
But I don't know how you try it without trying it. Like you have to have it at your desk, commit to it, try to use it, and then decide if you like it or not. And in this case, for me, the experience was fun in having built it. It worked, it was great. And I just didn't end up wanting to use it.
Yeah, but I think if you, maybe if you built one that was a little bit more traditional, you could use it every day. So that's my new project. Would it ever be comfortable enough where you could use it every day? Oh, I think so. Would it ever be comparable to? Yeah.
People use the similar, I guess, idea that this Kinesis. There's this Kinesis keyboard, which has been heard about. Oh, yeah. There's a buddy at work who has that. Yeah, I think it's pretty similar to that that i think it's a similar idea strain yeah so this would be really cool like if you are a um you know developer um you could totally build your own keyboard with one of these like you know cheap 3d printers or you could um do the thing where you 3d print it and they mail it to you and you could bring in your homemade keyboard
and do all your development on that. That would be some serious street cred. I mean, that's basically, I think this guy has like a video where he talks about this, yeah. Yeah, it's like, if you really need that, that, you know, promotion at work, you want to find out how to take it to the next level.
Jason's contention is this is like instant promotion material. I'm not sure I agree. Instant promotion, guaranteed. Your boss just walks by and he's like uh you know turns to your person next to you you say hey did you finish that report blah blah blah he walks by your desk he's like have i given you that promotion yet i think this is how you move from being like oh i was a kid who was picked on in high school to like oh a lot of people at work are like me. Oh, nope, I'm back to being picked on again. Oh my goodness.
I'll have to tell you one day the time when I sat in a tent at work where I installed a tent over my computer monitor. What? We have to keep going. Okay, we'll have to do that next show that sounds bizarre um all right it was logical i promise all right the nebraska problem so uh this is a article that's actually quite old from 2014 but the game the witness um which was written by oh why is his name uh escaping me it just escaped me oh jonathan blow thank you
uh so it's not by him. That is the guy who made The Witness, but he had like other people helping him. This is by, I think it's one of the people who helped him out on it. He worked on it. I haven't dug quite into it. Casey Muratori. But anyway, so for some reason, this got linked a while ago and I sort of kept it in my backlog and didn't lose all my bookmarks.
And so I had this. a while ago and and i sort of kept it my backlog and didn't lose all my bookmarks and so uh i had this and he's going through in this article basically ways of putting down clumps of grass which are like oh patrick why do we care like this is a programming podcast and we're now how long into the podcast and we've not talked about programming um so he's talking about uh randomly choosing locations to put down grass and one of the things he points out, which is, it comes up again and again, which is why I want to talk about this, is that randomness is actually pretty hard. So both for reasons of like, we're not going to get into and quantum physics and what is truly random and that most of the time what we call random is pseudo random.
I'm not talking about that. I mean, although those things are interesting, I would love to talk about them. Just from the fact that if you say he wanted to put down clumps of grass, and if you just randomly uniformly sample the space, pseudo randomly sample the space, you end up with clumps in some areas and gaps in other areas, which actually, although might be truly random,
looks bad. It doesn't look natural because grass doesn't end up being truly randomly distributed that way. And so you have some areas where it's dense and some areas where it's not. So now you need to- There's a natural process where grass is spreading and dying, right?
So what he, yes. And so what he's trying to do is, I don't know that he's per se seeking the biological defendable way of grass to be laid out in a field but he's showing how to do random sampling with what is that called like passan distribution or something where you're trying to like sample a set distance away from other plants so you're more likely to spawn where in an area where there are no plants than in an area with other plants yeah and and then also you could add increase the number of plants per area like the
density in total um but all of this door leads to gaps and he goes down to uh trying various methods and how to choose and and what he comes up with is goes on this deep dive and talks about how he he acknowledges this is a deep dive but it becomes this burning question in his mind and what he kind of figures out is actually he doesn't want something truly random what he finds out is that by choosing a pattern which is complex enough but is has certain properties he can get what he wants which is that when you're looking at it from sort of eye level out towards a horizon he can get it where there's no gaps and that it's not clear that it's a pattern but yet it is and you can use less features less of these plants and get the same effect and all
of that to say that he his quote-unquote random sampling in the end is actually that he said he doesn't go he's probably not gonna end up implementing it but that was this he called it staggered concentric intersections, where just sort of like this pattern with certain properties allowed him to cover the space in a way that was actually better than the truly just random distribution. And this comes up and came up actually at work where we kind of ran into this.
People were trying to test some stuff, and they were using just truly random tests. But what they were turning out is they weren't getting sort of great coverage. And what they didn't want was random sampling of the parameters, we actually wanted was some sort of preset coverage. So you could kind of guarantee that you covered as much as the input space as you can. So given that, hey, you're only going to be able to run 100 tests, how do you pick the 100 tests so that you get the most coverage possible instead of having risks of getting them clumped together? Yeah, that makes sense.
So basically, if some input is almost always 2 or something like that, but it has a range of 0 to 100, you don't want to waste a lot of time trying things that are way out there. Well, so yeah, that would be like- It's kind of like how if you have this grass, it's in the middle of nowhere. Yeah, so that would be like the reversing,
or the other way around is saying like, hey, you wanna make sure that this is well behaved. You get different behavior across zero to 100, but if you just pick 10 random samples, you're gonna get giant gaps most likely, versus what you could do is sample, if you have pick 10 random samples like you're going to get giant gaps most likely versus what you could do is sample you know if you have to sample 0 to 100 you could do 10 20 30 40 50 60 you know you could evenly space them and at least try to cover more of the area and the size of the gaps you have is going to be smaller and so there's a trade here without knowing what you're
trying to solve you can't say a priori, you know, hey, it's always better to random or it's somewhere in the middle. You want something that's random-ish, but what you don't want is probably truly random because truly random, you're going to end up with these gaps, these areas that aren't covered. That makes sense. Yeah, there's something like this in machine learning. I can't remember the term.
I mean, I think it's actually from statistics. It's called pseudo random but it's kind of overloading the term but basically it's a random number but you um you take as a prior the past numbers and so there's a there's a penalty for being close to one of the past numbers and so it's it's like this biased random number generator where it's more likely to generate a number that's far away from all the numbers it's generated in the past. Yeah. It's meant for like, yeah, like if you had, say, two dimensions, it'll try to generate a point that's far away from the other points. But then it'll make one random.
So it's like a combination of those two objectives. Yeah. So anyway, it's an interesting read and random is hard. Yeah, there's lots of random. So if you want to implement pseudo random numbers, you can do that in PyTorch. And PyTorch 1.0 came out in the past, I think it was last week or two weeks ago.
But basically, you know, TensorFlow is super, super popular. A lot of people are using TensorFlow and TensorFlow is great. PyTorch, you know, learned a lot of lessons from TensorFlow. And one of the things that PyTorch does really well is they have an immediate mode and then they have sort of a static mode. So the idea is, if you remember, like, you know, if you have compiled languages, interpreted languages, right, compiled languages are generally faster, because they can sort of look ahead, see sort of what's going to happen, or, you know, they can analyze the entire file,
take their time to try to optimize it, and do all of that before you run it, versus an interpreted, you know code in theory you could be kind of rewriting the code even as you're going along and things like that so you don't have the same assumptions um and so it's it's in machine learning you have sort of a similar concept where you have dynamic computation graphs or static computation graphs and as you would expect if you have a static computation graph it's going to go much faster because for example if there's some intermediate result that you're not using let's say you have you know z equals x plus y but you're not printing z or really doing anything with z you
just maybe you calculated it by accident or you deleted some other code that was using it, it just will skip that line. It says, oh, I don't need z. So boom, it's gone, right? So that's a pretty extreme example. But even if you're writing your code in a way where you're using everything, it's still much, much faster. It'll do all sorts of nice things there. But there are times that you need the dynamic graph.
So specifically, when you're trying to improve a model, like you're trying to have it train and learn and get better, that's when you typically need a dynamic graph, because you have to sort of react. It's like, let's say the model is really good. So you just want to stop training, right? Or let's say at the beginning of training, you want to do something, and then over time, you want to like switch to something else, right? So that's why dynamic graph is really useful. And also dynamic graph is easier to debug because, you know, because it's dynamic, you can stop it at any time. And so you can do all of that and then say, okay, now I'm good with
this. I want to switch to the static graph and get the speed. So I think TensorFlow 3, I want to say, is going to have this as well. So it's one of these things where everyone's learning from each other. If you have a huge project in TensorFlow, I probably wouldn't rewrite it. But PyTorch is super nice. If you're starting from scratch, PyTorch would definitely be the way to go, at least right now. And the 1.0 release came out, which really means that they have good documentation
and all of that. So check it out. Switching gears completely, don't have a good segue, is the Cosmic Ladder. So again, this is not really news, but this was a very interesting thing for me. So I thought I'd share it that somehow this came up.
What are we talking about? Something. And I did some research and found out, how do you tell how far away something is in space? So it turns out like a lot of people think they know and most people don't. So most engineers, well, most people probably don't care, to be fair. But most. Yeah, actually, I have no idea. I mean, I guess you have to do it based on the movement, right?
Yes. Okay, so this is what most engineers end up guessing. I'll say what you're saying is parallax, which is if you know that the Earth is moving and you see how things are moving relative to each other, you can sort of use trigonometry, roughly, and tell how far away something is. Yeah, right. Sure. how things are moving relative to each other you can you know sort of use trigonometry roughly and tell how far away something is yeah right sure but it turns out that only works uh out to a kind of a
certain distance uh because other things are just i mean i think it's like roughly 10 to the 24 miles away or something like it basically breaks down right You end up with your noise and your measurement is so big that you can't get useful information about how things, orders of magnitude further away end up still tiny in your computation. And so the cosmic ladder is a term that has Wikipedia and entry and everything. But the link I'll give here is by a person named terry tau and they i have no idea their uh pedigree as astronomers as an astronomer but they have a pretty cool presentation and pdf and powerpoint slide about essentially climbing the ladder how that you and it takes you through the history and sort of the techniques. And at least it was straightforward to understand or make me think I understand how it works.
About how that you're able to measure things on Earth, figure out how far away the moon is, for instance. Well, first, how big is the Earth? Like, how did they even figure out how big the Earth was? Once you figure out how big the Earth is, you can make an estimate of how far away the moon is um by sort of measuring various various things i won't recite because i'll mess them up um then as you get better like now we can tell how big the moon is because uh we can use radar systems to measure like how far away it is and reference it to things on the ground and we get better and we can see how the first initial guess is how close or bad they were.
Then to about 100 light years away, you can use what Jason was sort of saying by like movement around the sun, you can use sort of parallax. But what do you use for things that are like 10 to the 5 light years away? You have to use various fitting techniques to things which you believe have constantness. So if you imagine, and I might mess these up. So as you start going far away, you start saying, hey, it is repeatable that when a supernova occurs, that a supernova has a set brightness. So if I observe this, and this isn't exactly true, I'm waving my hands a lot.
If I know a supernova has a set brightness, then if I see a supernova and i measure how bright it is then i know how far away it is and so by having having a predictive model of how two things like how two binary dwarf stars orbit each other how fast that should happen and then by measuring you know how how far apart they are how big they are i can tell how far away they are um you can start to use periods of movement these kinds of things to try to guess how far away things are and he's essentially talking about how that once you can measure things a little further away then you can use those things to measure the things further away and you can sort of walk
your way up the ladder and to me it was just like whoa i wow that's never really thought about it that like some of these phenomenon are predicted by current physics of occurring in a set way like things will and certain stars will implode based on their mass and size and therefore you can predict their brightness and as we get better at understanding those predictions then we can use them to sort of measure how far away they are wow that's amazing i don't if you have that reminds me now i hope this isn't like uh totally off topic but but um i think it's similar you know how they measure i always wondered how they measure the weight of really small things like for example how do you measure the mass of a cork? And it turns out it's actually similar. So they, you know, you can't obviously put a cork on a scale or anything
like that. But what you can do is you can see what happens when a cork runs into something. And so you can see what happens when it bumps into something bigger than it. And then you can kind of see what happens when those things bump into something else, it um and then you can kind of see what happens when those things bump into something else so on and so forth and and and you can walk that sort of ladder backwards from something that is you know just big enough where you can weigh it and then looking at how um you know the the dynamics change when it collides into something smaller and you keep walking that ladder down until you get to a quark. And they actually use that same technique as you described to measure the mass of a quark.
Okay. Yeah, very cool. So I probably did a terrible job. If there's any astronomers in the audience, I'm sorry. But I found this interesting. And it turns out I'm not claiming what I said was, you know, more correct. You should go read about it. But, yeah, so it was surprising to me how much i didn't know about how distances were measured i
guess like jason was saying i never thought about how you would measure the weight of a cork uh but i guess it makes sense i guess the mass you measure it by bouncing it off other stuff and seeing how much it affects it yeah yeah totally yeah people are probably groaning cool no i thought that was actually one of the better, more interesting news stories we've had. So mine is much more straightforward and practical. It's an article on how to develop a boilerplate REST API. And so I actually found this because I was trying to do this.
51|||就像杰森刚才说的 我从来没想过你会去称一个软木塞的重量 呃，不过我想这倒也说得通 我想你测量它的质量 是通过把它弹到其他东西上 看看它对别的东西影响有多大 对吧 对，完全是这样 每个人可能都在发牢骚 酷，不，我觉得这其实是我们做过的最好、最有趣的新闻故事之一。所以我的要直接和实用得多。这是一篇关于如何开发样板 REST API 的文章。其实我发现这篇文章是因为我当时正打算这么做。
And I've done this before. So I was really just looking for a more recent version of this. And I went through a few of them. I was actually really happy with this one. And basically, I wanted to spin up a really simple website. And I wanted it to just have a few calls. People would call it with a few different URLs. And it would just spit back some JSON data.
而且我以前也做过。所以我其实只是在找这个的更新版本。我浏览了其中的几篇。我对这篇其实非常满意。基本上，我想要搭建一个非常简单的网站。我希望它只有几个调用。人们会用几个不同的 URL 来调用它。然后它就会吐出一些 JSON 数据。
And so I wanted something very simple that could do that. It was going to talk to a database that had data from another program and I was really interested in that other program. So I want something quick, easy, low maintenance. And whenever I need something like this, I always turn to ExpressJS. I like it because it's Node.js. It's pretty easy to use. If I want to access it from a browser and do some client-side stuff, that's also going to be in JavaScript, so that's convenient. And the biggest thing is I wanted it to be kind of ready to go. I basically wanted it to bootstrap this app and get it to a point where I can
所以我想要一个能做到这一点的非常简单的东西。它将与一个数据库进行通信，该数据库拥有来自另一个程序的数据，我对那个另一个程序真的很感兴趣。所以我想要一些快速、简单、低维护的东西。每当我需要这样的东西时，我总是求助于 ExpressJS。我喜欢它，因为它基于 Node.js。它相当容易使用。如果我想从浏览器访问它并做一些客户端的事情，那也将是 JavaScript，所以这很方便。最重要的一点是，我希望它有点开箱即用。我基本上想引导这个应用程序，让它达到这样一个程度
just create a URL handle for get and post and just put what I need in there and launch it. And this website actually goes in good detail about, there's a thing called, there's actually a binary called express from the express js team and you pass some commands some switches to it and it just builds a whole website from nothing um and it talks about kind of what those switches do because if you set different ones you're gonna your website's gonna look a little different um so yeah check that out it's got it kind of covers everything in good detail so time for book of the show book of the show my book of the show is enlightenment now by steven pinker um it's pretty cool it's it covers as it suggests the enlightenment period and it talks about how the um it actually kind of frames
我只需为 get 和 post 创建一个 URL 句柄，把需要的东西放进去然后启动它就行了。这个网站实际上对以下内容进行了很好的详细介绍：有一个叫作...实际上 express js 团队有一个叫 express 的二进制文件，你向它传递一些命令、一些开关，它就能从无到有地构建整个网站，呃，它还讨论了这些开关的作用，因为如果你设置了不同的开关，你的网站看起来会有所不同，呃，所以是的，去看看吧，它对所有内容都进行了很好的详细介绍——现在是本期图书时间。本期图书，我推荐的书是史蒂芬·平克的《当下的启示》 呃，这挺酷的，正如它所暗示的，它涵盖了启蒙运动时期，并且讨论了呃
the current day as a second enlightenment. So I'm not going to go through the whole book. It's a pretty long book. I'm not going to spoil the ending, although it's a historical book. So you're kind of living the ending. But the idea is you had the Dark Ages. A lot of works of knowledge were lost. They were either burned or the people carrying them fled out of Europe.
它实际上把现代视为第二次启蒙。所以我不会通读整本书。这是一本挺厚的书。我不会剧透结局，尽管这是一本历史书。所以你有点在亲历这个结局。但这个想法是，你曾经历过黑暗时代。很多知识著作都丢失了。它们要么被烧毁，要么携带它们的人逃离了欧洲。
And then you talk about the Enlightenment where all of this knowledge was restored and really people's perception changed. Actually, one of the things that I found really fascinating is they talk about the difference before and after the Enlightenment in terms of what people believed. So, for example, people believed before the Enlightenment that if you, let's say, killed someone with a knife and you brought that knife later on, even years later, to the body or the grave of the person that the person would bleed.
然后你谈到启蒙运动，所有这些知识都得到了恢复，人们的看法真的发生了改变。实际上，我发现非常fascinating（迷人）的一点是，他们谈到了启蒙运动前后人们信仰的差异。例如，在启蒙运动之前，人们相信如果你，比方说，用一把刀杀了一个人，然后你在后来，甚至多年后，把那把刀带到那个人的尸体或坟墓前，那个人会流血。
So in other words, like, you kill someone with a knife, and two weeks later, if you brought the knife to the person, to their corpse, the corpse would start bleeding. And that's how you could tell, you know, who was guilty, like, who did it. Like, spontaneously bleed. And that was just one thing. But basically, you know, people, I mean, they believed alchemy, rightchemy right that like you could turn metal to gold maybe that's true how i mean it was supernova maybe or something um but but yeah i mean people believed just unbelievable things i mean we've all
换句话说，就像，你用一把刀杀了某人，两周后，如果你把刀带到那个人、带到他们的尸体前，尸体会开始流血。这就是你能看出，你知道的，谁是凶手，比如，是谁干的的方法。就像自发流血一样。这只是一件事。但基本上，你知道的，人们，我的意思是，他们相信炼金术，炼金术对吧，就像你可以把金属变成黄金，也许那是真的，怎么说呢，我的意思是，也许是超新星什么的，呃，但是，但是，是的，我的意思是，人们相信简直难以置信的事情，我的意思是，我们都
heard about like that that maggots you know are created in meat you know like things like that like and just he lists off all these things that people believed and they're all just you know ridiculous kind of superstition right they're just perversions of nature and then he just says you know and in and 50 or 100 years later all of that is gone like like people just you know would look at you like you're crazy like like they would now if you if you said any of these things and just what an enormous transformation that was and um and he's talking he talks about basically how we've been going through just enormous transformations ever since uh the enlightenment and um i thought it was a fascinating book i'm still about halfway
听说过，就像蛆虫，你知道的，是在肉里产生的，你知道的，诸如此类的事情，他列举了人们相信的所有这些事情，它们都只是，你知道的，荒谬的迷信，对吧，它们只是对自然的曲解，然后他说，你知道的，在50年或100年后，所有这一切都消失了，就像人们只会，你知道的，看着你就像看着疯子一样，就像他们现在如果，如果你说了这些话一样，这是多么巨大的转变啊，呃，而且他在谈论，他基本上在谈论自启蒙运动以来我们一直在经历着多么巨大的转变，呃，我原以为这是一本引人入胜的书，我还在看大约一半
through it um the one thing i'll say is i don't think steven pinker is a good writer so he has amazing ted talks i feel like his writing is quality is very poor to be to be completely honest um there's i would say in about 10 or 20 percent of the sentences, he puts a string of about eight or 10 adjectives. And I'm not even kidding. It's like, you know, we thought that we were in the dark, gloomy, like desperate, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah era. But now we're in the blah, blah. And like so many adjectives. And it just, it was almost like just, it became kind of like a joke where I started counting all the adjectives.
读完它，呃，我要说的一件事是，我不认为史蒂芬·平克是个好作家，所以他的 ted 演讲很精彩，我觉得他的写作质量非常差，说实话，呃，大概有 10% 到 20% 的句子，他会连着用大约八到十个形容词。我真的一点都没开玩笑。就像，你知道的，我们曾认为我们处于黑暗、阴暗、绝望，诸如此类，诸如此类的时代。但现在我们在，诸如此类。有这么多的形容词。而且，这几乎就像，变成了一个笑话，我开始数所有的形容词。
So, yeah, you have to sort of get past the writing in a sense. But the content I felt like was really fascinating. And I would still, you know, even knowing that, I would still read it again. Like if I wasn't already halfway through it. My book will probably not enlighten you. It's a fiction book the bands of mourning uh which is a brandon sanderson novel who i recommend i feel like i'm on a i think he released a lot of books and i uh have been sort of catching up on them versus a lot of authors i
所以，是的，从某种意义上说，你得试着忽略这种文笔。但我觉得内容真的很吸引人。而且我还是会，你知道的，即使知道了这一点，我还是会再读一遍。就好像我还没有读到一半似的。我的书可能不会启迪你。这是一本小说，布兰登·桑德森的小说《哀悼美声》，我推荐这位作家，我觉得我好像在，我觉得他出了很多书，我一直在赶进度，而相比很多作家，我
am caught up on so i feel like his name gets brought up a bunch um i it's not that i i wish i had other stuff i've just been reading a lot of uh more parts of series and so since i like brandon sanderson so much and constantly try to tell people how they should read brandon sanderson books um i will say that i this is the third book in the second trilogy of this sort of like part of his universe so book six or whatever um and i think there's one more in this trilogy which is set sort of at a later date from the first trilogy in this part um but it's a it's in the mistborn series and so uh it's related to those books can't say a lot because it's the sixth book
已经追上了进度，所以我觉得他的名字经常被提起，我，并不是说我，我希望我有别的东西，我只是在读很多系列的小说，既然我这么喜欢布兰登·桑德森，并且经常试图告诉别人他们应该怎么读布兰登·桑德森的书，我要说的是，这是他的这个宇宙的第二部曲中的第三本书，所以大约是第六本，而且我认为这个三部曲中还有一本，它的设定时间比这一部分的第一个三部曲要晚一些，但它是《迷雾之子》系列的一部分，所以，呃，它与这些书有关，不能说太多，因为这是第六本
so uh it will just spoil literally everything so i can't talk about it. But if you have not heard me say how amazing Brandon Sanderson is, Brandon Sanderson is amazing and go read his books. Cool. The first Mistborn is good to start with. And yeah, I don't know. If you want recommendations, not on social media, but Jason can tell me people are asking. But also, I mean, I think there's plenty of guides
所以，呃，这简直会剧透一切，所以我不能谈论它。但是如果你还没有听我说过布兰登·桑德森有多么惊艳，布兰登·桑德森非常惊艳，快去读他的书吧。酷。第一本《迷雾之子》是个不错的起点。而且，是的，我不知道。如果你想要推荐，别在社交媒体上，但杰森可以告诉我有人在问。不过还有，我的意思是，我觉得有很多指南
just like where to start brandon sanderson i'm also reading the the his stormlight archives is another series he's writing he's a very you say like prolific is that the right word yeah i guess prolific writer he writes a lot like he comes out with a lot of books um and like very big books and i have no idea how other writers, which I won't name, seem to struggle like getting their series done or coming out with their next book. This guy just burns through them. I don't, I think maybe,
就像从哪里开始读布兰登·桑德森一样，我也在读他的《风暴档案》，这是他在写的另一个系列，他是一个非常，你会说“多产”吗，这是正确的词吗？对，我想是个多产的作家，他写了很多，比如他出版了很多书，而且都是很厚的大书，我不知道其他作家——我就不点名了——为什么似乎在完成他们的系列或推出下一本书时那么挣扎。这家伙写得太快了。我不知道，也许，
maybe it's just like a, what do you call it? It's like a machine learned writer. Like he just, it's just like a Markov process. And he just like, it's just randomly generating the sentences for him, but he's done, he's like the world's best trainer of a markov process and he just like it's just randomly generating the sentences for him but he's done he's like the world's best trainer of a of a markov process and he's just like yeah yeah i don't care if it is i don't even care i wonder if uh what's actually happening is is he's
也许这就像一个，你叫它什么？这就像一个机器学习的作家。就像他，这就像一个马尔可夫过程。他就像，这只是在为他随机生成句子，但他完成了，他就像是马尔可夫过程的世界最佳训练师，他就像，这只是在为他随机生成句子，但他完成了，他就像是马尔可夫过程的世界最佳训练师，而且他就像，是啊，是啊，我不在乎是不是，我甚至不在乎，我在想，实际上发生的情况是，他
he's got a team of people who really help him and and he is at the you know he's orchestrating it but other people are maybe filling in some of the thematic points or something. It could be. I mean, I don't think so. I was trying to think is I think we were talking about how, oh, I thought I knew how to measure how far away stars were. It turns out I didn't. I think if I if you actually sit down and calculate the amount of time it takes to write even a thousand page book, like just write the words. If you worked on it each day for a few hours right it's not that long um i don't think uh oh i thought you were gonna say
他有一支真正帮助他的团队，而且他处于，你知道的，他在策划这一切，但其他人可能在填充一些主题要点之类的东西。有可能。我的意思是，我不这么认为。我在想，我想我们之前在讨论，哦，我以为我知道怎么测量星星有多远了。结果我并不知道。我想如果你真的坐下来计算一下写一本一千页的书所需的时间，比如仅仅是写这些文字。如果你每天都在上面花几个小时，写，这其实没那么久，呃，我不认为，呃，哦，我还以为你要说
it's very long no i think it's right a thousand page book um how many words are on a page like roughly what okay we can do this on the air i i should have come prepared so we'll say to write 200 words i think it's gonna take you i i feel like it would take a thousand say to write 200 words, I think it's going to take you. I feel like it would take a thousand hours to write a thousand page book. So it says it's about 250 to 300 pages per word or per page. Two hundred and fifty words per page. Yeah. So, yeah, I would say about about a thousand hours just to write it. Assuming like let's say you were just copying um you think from another book right
这非常久。不，我觉得对吧，一本一千页的书，一页上有多少个字？大概多少？好吧，我们可以在节目里算一下，我本来应该做点准备的，所以我们假设写 200 个字，我觉得你需要，我感觉这会花，比如写 200 个字，我觉得你需要。我感觉写一本一千页的书需要一千个小时。所以上面说每字或每页大约是 250 到 300 页。每页两百五十个字。是的。所以，是的，我可以说大约需要一千个小时来写。假设，比方说你只是在复制，呃，你觉得是从另一本书里吗？
like what's your words per minute when you type oh really bad i told you i'm a terrible typist so let's say your words per minute is is uh 50 then that would be full five minutes yeah that's not very yeah okay copying would definitely be faster than that okay well um yeah whatever he writes really fast i don't know how he does it. Yeah, I mean, either way, it sounds remarkable that he can get that much done. So, yeah, so about five minutes per page, about 5,000 minutes. Is that right? Yeah, 5,000 minutes.
比如你打字时的每分钟字数是多少？哦，真的很差。我告诉过你我是个糟糕的打字员。所以假设你的每分钟字数是，呃，50，那么这将是整整五分钟。是的，这不太，是的，好吧，复制肯定比那要快。好吧，嗯，管他呢，他写得真快，我不知道他是怎么做到的。是的，我的意思是，不管怎样，他能完成这么多工作听起来真的很了不起。所以，是的，所以大约每页五分钟，大约 5,000 分钟。对吗？是的，5,000 分钟。
Yeah, so you could knock it out in a few weeks if you're just copying. So my guess is it probably takes him like three-ish months, let's say, or whatever. You know, four-ish months to write it. If like write a good solid chunk every day and you know where you're going and then he can do them in parallel so if he has people like you point out not help him write but help them do the editing like he writes the rough cut and has a lot of good people to help him proofread and edit it then you could sort of do two or three books per year i just think a lot of authors you know there's like they do book tours. It's like a whole process getting in a groove.
是的，所以如果你只是在抄写，你可以在几周内搞定它。所以我的猜测是，他大概花三个月左右，比方说，或者随便多久。你知道，四个月左右来写完它。如果每天都写扎实的一大块，而且你知道你要去哪里，然后他可以并行完成这些，如果他有像你指出的人不是帮他写，而是帮他做编辑——他写初稿，并有很多优秀的人帮他校对和编辑——那么你每年基本上可以写两三本书。我只是觉得很多作家，你知道，他们有图书巡回签售之类的。这就像是一个进入状态的整个过程。
You see this with musicians. Like I always think about this. Musicians come out with albums like once every couple years, if that. But like how long does it really take to make an album? Like, I mean, I don't know. I mean, it's basically two or three weeks to make the album. But then, you know know you're on tour playing the same song in every city for two years but you're i mean you're on tour playing the same
你从音乐家身上也能看到这一点。就像我总是这么想。音乐家每隔几年才出一张专辑，如果有的话。但制作一张专辑到底需要多长时间？我的意思是，我不知道。我的意思是，制作这张专辑基本上需要两三周的时间。但是接着，你知道的，你就在巡演，在每个城市连续两年演奏同一首歌，但你是在，我的意思是，你在巡演，演奏同样的
but you're only doing that a couple hours a day right or what's that i said uh you're only playing a couple hours a day for your concerts though yeah right yeah the concerts you're just you're just reciting you're not actually making music yeah basically i just don't understand like creative work i guess yeah it's mind-boggling that somebody can produce that much content so i mean meanwhile i i write a few lines of code a day and that's it maybe yeah when i hear about these indie game developers who do everything themselves like they do all the art they write all the the the the dialogue they do everything themselves yeah it boggles my mind but i mean they also take you know like like uh
但你每天只做几个小时，对吧？或者那是怎样的？我刚刚说，呃，你在演唱会上每天只演奏几个小时。对，没错，是的。在演唱会上你只是在背诵，你并不是真的在创作音乐。是的，基本上我就是不理解创意工作，我想是的。有人能产出这么多内容，这真是令人匪夷所思。所以，与此同时，我一天只写几行代码，仅此而已，也许吧。当我听到这些独立游戏开发者自己做所有事情时——他们做所有的美术，他们写所有的对话，他们自己做所有事情——是的，这让我大开眼界，但我的意思是，他们也花了，你知道的，就像
they also take a long time to to make the the game that's true but not always you ever what was what's the name of that jam the co-jam they do it like in a day oh yeah ludum dare and some of those games are pretty cool i mean they're not like true triple a titles but it's true they have a good mechanic and then they can always kind of write the game around that all right if you want to read about uh brendan sorenson did i say that brandon sanderson brandon sanderson or stephen pinker you can do it on audible i actually I actually listen to Enlightenment Now on Audible and I listen to a couple of other books. I wouldn't really put them as a book of the show.
他们制作游戏也花了很长时间。这倒也是，但并不总是这样。你有没有，那个叫什么来着，那个游戏创作比赛？他们一天就能搞定。哦，对，Ludum Dare，其中一些游戏挺酷的。我的意思是，它们不算是真正的 3A 大作，但确实如此，它们有一个很好的机制，然后他们总是可以围绕这个来编写游戏。好吧，如果你想读关于布兰登·索伦森的书——我是这么说的吗，布兰登·桑德森，布兰登·桑德森还是史蒂芬·平克？你可以在 Audible 上听。我其实，我其实是在 Audible 上听了《当下的启示》，我还听了其他几本书。我真的不会把它们当作本期图书。
I was running a bit behind in the sense that I was accumulating some credits on Audible. And so I got a couple of lighthearted books. And so actually I'll make a book of the show next time. But I got a couple of comedy books. I got a couple of lighthearted books. And so actually, I'll make a book of the show next time. But I got a couple of comedy books. I got a couple of serious books. And I've been really doubling down on the Audible. It's been a lot of fun.
我当时有点落后，因为我在 Audible 上积累了一些积分。所以我买了几本轻松的书。所以实际上我下次再推荐本期图书吧。但我买了几本喜剧书。我买了几本轻松的书。所以实际上，我下次再推荐本期图书吧。但我买了几本喜剧书。我买了几本严肃的书。我一直在 Audible 上加大投入。这真的很有趣。
Nice. Yeah. If you don't want to support us on Audible, if you already have an Audible account, or you just want to find a different way to support the show, we are on Patreon. If you donate, I think it's as little as a dollar i don't think they'll let you donate fractions of a dollar but no matter what you donate you get all the benefits so you get the rss feed which is much faster than the default rss feed like the download rate is much higher um and uh you get to be in the raffle, which is coming up. So this Christmas, last Christmas, we gave out laser printed programming throwdown logos and some T-shirts.
太棒了。是的。如果你不想在 Audible 上支持我们，如果你已经有了 Audible 账户，或者你只是想找一种不同的方式来支持这个节目，我们在 Patreon 上。如果你捐赠，我想只需一美元，我不认为他们会允许你捐赠几美分的零头，但无论你捐赠多少，你都能获得所有的福利，所以你可以获得 RSS 订阅源，这比默认的 RSS 订阅源快得多，比如下载速度要高得多，而且，呃，你可以参加抽奖，抽奖活动马上就要开始了。所以今年圣诞节，去年圣诞节，我们送出了激光打印的编程抛掷秀标志和一些 T 恤。
This Christmas, we'll give out some more T-shirts and we'll have to figure out what we're going to do for all the Patreon folks. We'll try and do something a little different this year. But yeah, you'll get involved in that. You'll beaffled uh in the raffle for a t-shirt um and you'll definitely we'll try and get something to everybody um so yeah check us out on patreon time for and with that tools of the show tools of the show my tool of the show is quip so quip is pretty cool if you've ever used a google doc um Doc and you've done it in a collaborative way where you and someone else are both writing in the same doc, then you've basically used Quip. So it's very similar. The big thing about Quip is it's better for kind of, let's say,
今年圣诞节，我们会送出更多的 T 恤，我们还得想想我们要为所有 Patreon 的支持者做些什么。今年我们会尝试做点不一样的。但是的，你会参与其中。你将有机会在抽奖中赢得一件 T 恤，而且我们绝对会努力给每个人送点东西，所以，是的，在 Patreon 上关注我们——是时候进入节目工具环节了。节目工具，我的节目工具是 Quip。所以如果你用过谷歌文档，并且是以协作的方式使用过，也就是你和另一个人在同一个文档里写作，那么你基本上就用过 Quip。所以它非常相似。Quip 的最大特点是它更适合，比方说，
group projects. So it has folders, although I guess now Google Docs is a lot of the same features but you know quip is very sort of compartmentalized so you can have you know a whole quip kind of group for let's say you're working on a book or something like that with it with the group of people you can all be in the the same sort of quip server and it kind of keeps things organized like that you can you can share things you can collaborate um we use it at work it's um it's uh it's actually really nice and also if you're doing anything sort of um like private you can actually host quip like i think it costs money but you can host quip yourself like you can you can buy a license and all of that um if you don't
小组项目。所以它有文件夹，尽管我想现在的谷歌文档也有很多相同的功能，但你知道，Quip 非常分类明确，所以你可以拥有一个完整的 Quip 群组，比方说你正在和一群人一起写一本书或者类似的东西，你们都可以加入同一个 Quip 服务器，它会把事情组织得井井有条，你可以分享东西，可以协作，我们在工作中使用它，它，呃，其实真的很不错。而且如果你在做任何私密的事情，你实际上可以托管 Quip，我想这要花钱，但你可以自己托管 Quip，比如你可以买一个许可证之类的，如果你不
use google docs like your business or something like that um but yeah we've been you know i use it almost every day and it works really well what is uh your tool of the show oh my tool of the show is a game surprise don't do useful it's stardew valley which has been out for a while and i think we may have even talked about it i don't know that it's ever been the tool which has been out for a while and i think we may have even talked about it i don't know that it's ever been the tool of the show but we've may have talked about it before but it recently came out on i believe both ios and android i always mean to look this up and i forgot uh so yes it is oh really no way uh-huh yeah so ios is out now android is coming out it says cool so um i've been playing this android release date is i'm gonna scan this
在业务中使用谷歌文档或者类似的东西，但是，是的，我们一直，你知道的，我几乎每天都在用它，而且效果很好。你的节目工具是什么？哦，我的节目工具是一个游戏，惊喜吧，不是实用的东西，它是《星露谷物语》，这款游戏已经推出一段时间了，我想我们甚至可能讨论过它，我不知道它是否曾被选为节目工具，这款游戏已经推出一段时间了，我想我们甚至可能讨论过它，我不知道它是否曾被选为节目工具，但我们以前可能讨论过它，不过它最近在，我相信 iOS 和 Android 平台上都发布了。我总是想查一下这个，但我忘了。所以是的，确实如此。哦，真的吗？不会吧。嗯哼，是的，所以 iOS 版已经上线了，安卓版即将推出，上面写着
while we talk oh pop over die so yeah basically stardew valley is actually one of these games that was created by just one person um they did all the dialogue they did all the art everything um but it took that person literally like, I think, seven years to make that game. Oh, wow. Unbelievable level of effort. I didn't realize that. Yeah. So I can't tell if it's out or not on Android. Someone with an Android phone will have to check. But it is on the app store I've been playing on my iPad. I don't know how it would play on an iPhone, but on an iPad, it's pretty good. It's one of those things where I always feel I'm just going to play it for a few more. Oh, there goes an hour.
太酷了，所以我一直在玩这个。安卓版的发布日期是，我边聊边扫一眼这个。哦，快倒下吧。所以，是的，基本上《星露谷物语》其实就是那种由一个人独立开发的游戏，他们包办了所有的对话、所有的美术，所有的一切，但那个人为了制作这款游戏，literally（简直）花了，我想，大约七年的时间。哦，天哪。令人难以置信的努力程度。我之前没意识到这一点。是的。所以我看不出它在安卓上是否已经上线。有安卓手机的人得去查证一下。但它确实在应用商店里，我一直在我的 iPad 上玩。我不知道它在 iPhone 上玩起来会怎么样，但在 iPad 上，它相当不错。这属于那种让我总是觉得“我再玩一会儿”的游戏。哦，一个小时又过去了。
Yeah, yeah. Well, the thing about Stardew Valley is basically just a recap is you're kind of like a farmer, but some of the sort of ingredients, more advanced things, you have to go into dangerous places. So you're like a farmer and a soldier at the same time. And the game can only save at night so basically you do a bunch of things and then and then during the day you get so tired from doing these things that you have to go to sleep or or maybe you don't get that tired by nighttime you're forced to go to sleep but then it's like the moment the game saves is the moment when you have something to do it's like oh now i have all this energy and the game just saved um and it's like when you don't have any energy and you're really
是的，是的。嗯，《星露谷物语》的特点是，基本上总结一下，你就像是一个农民，但其中一些成分，一些更高级的东西，你必须去危险的地方。所以你既是一个农民，同时又是一个士兵。而且这个游戏只能在晚上保存，所以基本上你做了一堆事情，然后，然后白天你做这些事情累得要命，以至于你不得不去睡觉，或者也许你没有那么累，到了夜里你被迫去睡觉，但随后，就像游戏保存的那个瞬间，正是你有事情可做的时候，就像，哦，现在我有了所有的精力，而游戏刚刚保存了，这就好像，当你没有任何精力，而且你真的
ready to like call it a night that's when like you you can't really save you have to wait until the night's over so anyways i'm kind of messing this up but basically the way they do this save really kind of keeps you playing. That's a great hook. Yeah, I mean, I think said another way, when you wake up first thing in the morning, it's a new day. But that means you need to do all the day's chores. Like you have to make sure all your plants are watered. You need to go take care of stuff.
准备好“今晚就到这里吧”，那就是你无法真正保存的时候，你必须等到夜晚结束。无论如何，我把这弄得有点乱，但基本上他们进行这种保存的方式确实让你一直玩下去。这真是一个巨大的吸引力。是的，我的意思是，换句话说，当你一大早醒来时，这是新的一天。但这意味着你需要做完一天所有的杂务。比如你必须确保你所有的植物都浇过水了。你需要去处理各种事情。
So when you have the most energy, you have the most things you need to do. And then by the end of the day, you run out of energy, but you can't get new one without ending the day and having to go spend your energy again. So you can try to cook yourself meals or do other things to restore your energy. But yeah, as Jason's pointing out, mostly you have a set number of things you need to do and then a bunch of the optional things. And turns out it's kind of like real life. You have more things that you need or want to do during the day than you have energy to do or time to get done.
所以当你拥有最多精力的时候，也是你最需要做的事情最多的时候。然后到了快天黑时，你的精力耗尽了，但如果不结束这一天并再次消耗你的精力，你就无法获得新的精力。所以你可以试着自己做饭或其他事情来恢复精力。但是，是的，正如杰森指出的那样，主要来说，你有一组必须要做的事情，然后还有一堆可选的事情。结果证明这有点像现实生活。你在白天需要或想做的事情，比你有精力去做或有时间完成的事情要多。
Yeah, I mean, put it another way. I'll take a second. Oh, here we go. We're going to just go around and around. The most exciting part of the game happens right after you save. That's maybe a better way of saying what I was trying to say earlier. So it's like as soon as you save, as soon as the game saves, you have all these things you need to do and they're all really fulfilling.
是的，换句话说。我花一秒钟。哦，这里我们来了。我们要兜圈子了。游戏中最激动人心的部分恰好发生在保存之后。这也许是表达我刚才想说的话的更好方式。所以就像一旦你保存了，一旦游戏保存了，你就有所有这些你需要做的事情，而且它们都非常充实。
It's like, oh, I have a plant that's ready for a harvest and I have a new set of grapes or something like that. It's like the coolest stuff in the game is always right after you save. And so once you've done that cool stuff, then you're kind of stuck until you don't want to waste the rest of the day. So you're stuck until it saves. And then right when it saves, there's something else cool to do yeah so i i mean i enjoy there's the new trend which this isn't this game has been out for a while but it's just coming to mobile uh or to ios and android and i don't know how all those are mobile anymore anyways but um is that it's open world without being uh no too much to do.
这就像，哦，我有一株植物可以收获了，我还有一串新葡萄或者类似的东西。这就像游戏中最高酷的事情总是发生在保存之后。所以一旦你完成了那些酷的事情，然后你就有点被困住了，直到你不想浪费剩下的时间。所以你被困住了，直到它保存。然后就在它保存的时候，还有另一件酷事等着去做。是的，所以，我的意思是，我喜欢，有一种新趋势——虽然这游戏已经推出一段时间了，但它刚刚登陆移动端，或者说登陆了 iOS 和 Android，而且我不知道这一切到底是不是移动端——无论如何，那就是它是开放世界的，却没有……没有太多要做的事。
So there's always something simple you can do. There's enough story where it's trying to push you like, hey, go check this out or go check that out. The trend in open world games seems to be a lot like, do anything you want. And then that just makes me not want to do anything at all. Yeah, that totally makes sense. So it's just directed enough.
所以总有一些你可以做的简单的事情。有足够的故事在推动你，比如，“嘿，去看看这个”或“去看看那个”。开放世界游戏的趋势似乎非常类似于：你想做什么就做什么。然后这反而让我什么都不想做了。是的，这完全说得通。所以它的引导性刚刚好。
Cool, all right so on to the topic the topic is teaching kids to code and um this is there's a lot going on here actually we should start we should preface this by saying you know why we could why we're an authority on this why would you even listen to us talk about this? So don't. That's pretty nihilistic. Thank you. Yeah, so basically, so we have, I think, relatively different background,
酷，好的，那么进入主题，主题是教孩子们编程，呃，这里面其实有很多内容，我们应该以此作为开场白：为什么我们可以教，为什么我们有资格谈论这个？为什么要听我们谈论这个？所以，别听。这挺虚无主义的。谢谢。是的，所以基本上，所以我们有，我认为，相对不同的背景，
maybe not that different. So your dad was also a coder, right? In my case, my dad was an engineer. I wasn't really a coder, but my aunt was a coder. Yes. Right. In my case, my dad was an engineer. I wasn't really a coder. But my aunt was a software engineer. So we definitely both kind of had it in the family in a sense. And we can talk about, I guess, how our family got us into coding or at least how our family was part of that. And then now we also have kids. Your kids are probably too young to really do a lot of coding. I mean, mine definitely are. But do you do have kids uh your kids are probably too young to really do a lot of coding i mean mine
也许没那么不同。所以你爸爸也是个程序员，对吧？就我而言，我爸爸是个工程师。我其实不是个程序员，但我姑姑是个程序员。是的。没错。就我而言，我爸爸是个工程师。我其实不是个程序员。但我姑姑是个软件工程师。所以从某种意义上说，我们家里确实都有人吃这碗饭。我们可以谈谈，我猜，我们的家庭是如何把我们引入编程的，或者至少我们的家庭是如何参与其中的。现在我们也有孩子了。你的孩子可能太小了，还不能做很多编程。我的绝对是。但是你有孩子，你的孩子可能太小了，还不能做很多编程，我的
definitely are but do you do do your kids do any coding no so they don't do coding yet my my older daughter has wanted to she calls it like have computer lessons but it turns out the thing that you at least i never think about is how much it requires reading uh so yeah so if your kids can't actually like read at a significant level it's pretty hard to get them to sort of do some fundamental things on the computer so like anytime there's an error message pop up they don't know what it says yeah exactly yeah so our kids are still too young but um we could talk about i guess that's actually when it's most interesting right because i mean if if if someone is like 18 or something then it's it's or that's a bad example someone's like out of 14 then maybe it's the same instructions as if they were 18 right but i mean i do say that i think my kids have begun to engage on things where
绝对是，但是你的孩子们会做任何编程吗？没有，所以他们还不做编程。我的大女儿一直想，她称之为“上电脑课”，但事实是，你——至少我从没想过——这需要大量的阅读，所以，是的，如果你的孩子们实际上不能达到相当高的阅读水平，要让他们在电脑上做一些基础的事情是相当困难的，所以任何时候弹出错误消息，他们都不知道上面写的是什么。是的，完全正确。是的，所以我们的孩子们还太小，但是，呃，我们可以谈谈，我猜这其实是最有趣的时候，对吧？因为我的意思是，如果，如果有人大概 18 岁左右，那么它，或者这是一个不好的例子，如果有人大概 14 岁左右，那么也许指令就和他们 18 岁时一样，对吧？但我确实要说，我认为我的孩子们已经开始接触一些事情，对
for me like the teaching them to code isn't so much about like in a programming language, but I guess teaching them things which are, I guess I take for granted, but are not always immediately obvious to people like describing a sequence of events unambiguously to be done. And so, yeah, doing exercises where then where I'm like, we're going to play a game and then trying to have them like, let's say what you want done, but then, oh wait, what you said was ambiguous and therefore it can be executed in lots of ways or playing, you know, playing board games or what if experiments with them and having them try to think like why something happened. And it's like, I know you could just try this or do this in this video game we're playing, but why not? What do you think will happen? Like, let's not just go mash the button until the door opens. Like what thing do you think will happen like let's not just go mash the button until the door
我来说，教他们编程与其说是在教一种编程语言，不如说是教他们一些我认为理所当然、但对人们来说并不总是不言而喻的事情，比如毫不含糊地描述要执行的一系列事件。所以，是的，做一些练习，我就会说，我们要玩一个游戏，然后试着让他们，比如，说出你想做什么，但是，等等，你刚才说的话含糊不清，因此它可以通过多种方式执行，或者玩，你知道的，玩棋盘游戏，或者和他们一起做“如果”实验，让他们试着思考为什么会发生某事。这就像，我知道你可以尝试这个，或者在我们玩的这个电子视频游戏里做这个，但为什么不呢？你觉得会发生什么？我们不要只是狂按按钮直到门打开。比如你觉得会发生什么，我们不要只是狂按按钮直到门
opens like what thing do you think we could do that would open the door in this game and trying to have them think about like sort of cause and effect um when even we're doing other tasks because i think that's something that a lot of gets missed which is a lot of stuff gets missed which is people just sort of bang their way through games or playing stuff until it works but trying to anticipate like if i do this action that thing's gonna happen and i guess it's almost about teaching a kid how to debug before teaching them to program um but i spent a lot of time doing that with my kids yeah i mean i i uh i play um play a lot of board games with my with my son too and i think uh you know my parents also played a lot of board games with my son too. And I think my parents also played a lot of board games with me. We used to play Monopoly and stuff like that.
打开，比如你觉得我们在游戏中可以做什么来打开门，并试着让他们在做其他任务时也思考因果关系，因为我认为这是很多人忽略的，有很多东西都被忽略了，那就是人们只是在游戏中盲目闯关或玩游戏直到成功，但试着去预测：如果我做这个动作，那件事就会发生。我想这几乎就像在教一个孩子如何在编程之前进行调试，但我花了很多时间跟我的孩子们做这件事。是的，我的意思是，我，我玩，我和我的儿子也玩很多棋盘游戏，我认为，你知道，我的父母也经常和我儿子玩棋盘游戏。我想我的父母以前也经常陪我玩棋盘游戏。我们过去常常玩大富翁之类的游戏。
And the interesting thing about board games is there are some things in board games you can control and there are some things you can't. And I think that as an adult, it's kind of obvious. But as a kid, I think that that's a really kind of important thing to learn. Like, like if you, you know, if your parents like always get bad roles on Monopoly and they'd end up with no properties and they lose, uh, like, you know, a lot of kids think their parents are kind of superheroes, right? So it's like where you're, where you see your parents fail, you kind of see like, oh, okay. That was kind of randomness. You know, my dad got go to jail three times in a row or something like that. And he's, you know, frustrated about it or whatever. And then he
棋盘游戏有趣的地方在于，有些事情在棋盘游戏里是你能控制的，有些事情是你无法控制的。我认为作为一个成年人，这挺显而易见的。但作为一个孩子，我认为这是非常重要的一课。比如，如果你，你知道的，如果你的父母在大富翁里总是掷出烂点数，最后名下没有房产并且输了，呃，你知道的，很多孩子认为他们的父母某种程度上是超级英雄，对吧？所以你会看到你的父母失败，你就会看到，哦，好吧。那有点纯属运气。你知道的，我爸爸连续三次被关进监狱或者诸如此类的事。而他对此感到沮丧什么的。然后他
loses. It's like, okay, that was something you couldn't control. But you know, not putting houses anywhere, you know, that caused me to lose and I could have just put houses, you know what I mean? Like, as you said, the cause and effect and also more like the framing, like understanding where you have sort of control and where things are happening outside of your control and being able to disambiguate those two, like pulling the signal from the noise. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, I think, you know, actually, we interviewed Mark Engleberg a while back and he um people should definitely check that the interview out it was fascinating but he actually um you know made several games and puzzles and things like that and so i think that's a great way to get started is um is by checking out uh you know board games like you know when i was a kid i didn't really
输了。这就好像，好吧，那是你无法控制的事情。但你知道的，到处都不建房子，你知道的，这导致我输了，我本可以建房子的，你知道我的意思吗？就像你说的，因果关系，还有更重要的框架，比如理解你在哪些方面有控制权，哪些事情发生在你的控制之外，并能够区分这两者，把信号从噪声中分离出来。是的，这说得通。是的，我认为，实际上，我们不久前采访了马克·英格伯格，他，呃，人们绝对应该去听听那次采访，太精彩了。但他实际上，你知道的，制作了几个游戏、谜题和类似的东西，所以我认为这是一个很好的切入点，那就是去了解，你知道的，棋盘游戏，比如我小时候并不真正
know of any i'm sure they existed but i didn't really know of any sort of, board games. Like, you know, when I was a kid, I didn't really know of any, I'm sure they existed, but I didn't really know of any sort of educational board games. We mostly just played, you know, Monopoly. We played Sorry. We played just, you know, I guess just adult board games. Actually, I do remember playing Chutes and Ladders and things like that too. But now, I mean, there's games for kids and to some extent games for adults that are that are way better like they're they're better balanced they like kind of teach you more um and so think fun you know is is uh has put out some really fantastic games and they're actually coming out with i think a couple new games um i saw on their website they're coming out with potato pirates which is a game for like seven and up and they're coming out with Potato Pirates which is a game for like
知道任何教育类棋盘游戏，我确信它们存在，但我真的不知道任何这类游戏。我们大多数时候只是玩，你知道的，大富翁。我们玩《Sorry!》（人在江湖）。我们只是，你知道的，我猜就是玩成人棋盘游戏。其实，我还记得玩过《蛇梯棋》（Chutes and Ladders）之类的游戏。但现在，我的意思是，有适合儿童的游戏，在某种程度上也有更适合成人的游戏，它们要好得多——它们平衡性更好，能教给你更多东西，所以 ThinkFun 推出了一些非常棒的游戏，他们实际上要推出，我想是几款新游戏，
7 and up and they're coming out with some game called Hacker for 10 and up and yeah I haven't had a chance to really play those yet or I don't think they're out yet but you know there's educational games I think are really nice so the games that Mark built
我在他们的网站上看到他们将推出《土豆海盗》（Potato Pirates），这是一款针对 7 岁及以上儿童的游戏，他们将推出一款名为《黑客》（Hacker）的游戏，适合 10 岁及以上儿童，是的，我还没有机会真正玩过这些，或者我觉得它们还没上市，但我认为教育游戏真的很不错。所以马克制作的游戏
and like this Robot Turtles and stuff what it taught me is like when playing with my kids the thing that's interesting is having them learn which at first i didn't get but when you say go left they think about like i'm viewing the board the the thing is going to go to my left and it's like no it's executing from some other point of view so like i'm moving this robot forward so in robot i've been to lots of things roughly you're describing some sequence of actions you wanted to take like go straight rotate left go straight and this like when you're in an area and teachers like teaching the kids the the context in which something runs which to me at first was like oh i don't they're having struggles with this and this doesn't seem related to programming.
就像这个《机器人海龟》（Robot Turtles）之类的东西，它教会我的是，在和我的孩子们玩的时候，有趣的事情是让他们学习我一开始没懂的东西——当你让他们“向左走”时，他们会认为，我是从自己的视线来看棋盘的，这个东西会走到我的左边去，而事实并非如此，它是从其他某个观点在执行。所以就像我在把这个机器人向前移动，所以在机器人里，我经历过很多事情，大致就是描述你希望它采取的一系列动作，比如直行、向左转、直行，这就像当你身处一个区域时，老师就像在教孩子们程序运行的上下文，对我来说一开始觉得：哦，我不希望他们在这些方面挣扎，这看起来和编程没关系。
But I've come around to actually thinking that programming is about putting yourself in the context of the code running, which is the things around you when you run matter a lot. So if I add one to a number when the number is 10, it becomes 11, not going from zero to one or whatever. You know, like understanding, keeping in mind what the current state is and so like looking at visually at the board and saying hey the turtle is currently facing to the left if i have it turn left it's not going to go to my left it's going to go down then to me it's like oh this is this is obvious right like oh this is easy but but to a kid like wrapping yourself up and i need to put myself in his shoes or into the context of where the program is at, where it's running. And then having kid be able to walk back to where it went wrong is actually pretty useful. And as Jason pointed out, I mean, as far as like becoming an expert
但我后来开始真正认为，编程其实就是把自己代入代码运行的上下文环境中，也就是你运行代码时周围的环境非常重要。所以如果我在数字是 10 的时候给它加 1，它就会变成 11，而不是从 0 变到 1 或其他什么。你知道，比如理解、记住当前的状态是什么，所以通过视觉观察棋盘，说“嘿，海龟目前面向左侧，如果我让它向左转，它不会朝我的左边走，它会朝下走”，对我来说，就会觉得“哦，这太明显了，对吧？哦，这太简单了”，但是对于一个孩子来说，要把自己裹挟进去，我需要设身处地为它着想，或者代入程序运行所在的上下文环境中。然后能让孩子自己走回出错的地方其实非常有用。正如杰森所指出的，我的意思是，至于是否能成为这方面的专家，
on it, I mean, TBD, we'll see, like, I don't know if it'll help my kids because I never played these kind of games growing up, but it is interesting to play them with with the kids so what did you do because you you if you didn't if you weren't playing board games and then uh yeah so slightly older than than that but i think once i was in later elementary and early middle school we had programming books and compilers on my computer programming books around the house and compilers on the computer um and so i taught myself sort of how to use q basic by reading the book and i like if i had got stuck or had a problem i'd get my you know dad to help me or whatever which which he would to some extent although i guess now his mindset was probably like i did this all day i
也就是有待确定，我们拭目以待，比如，我不知道这是否会对我的孩子们有帮助，因为我从小就没玩过这种游戏，但和孩子们一起玩这些游戏确实很有趣。那你做了什么呢？因为如果你没有，如果你当时没玩棋盘游戏，那么，是的，比那稍微大一点，但我想一旦我上了小学高年级和初中低年级，我的电脑上就有编程书和编译器，家里周围放着编程书，电脑上装有编译器，所以我通过读书自学了如何使用 QBasic，如果我卡住了或者遇到了问题，我会找我，你知道的，我爸爸来帮我，诸如此类的，他会在某种程度上帮忙，尽管我想他当时的 心态可能是像“我一整天都在干这个”
don't want to come home and do this with my kid you know like i can't blame him so we didn't do it for like hours upon end but i would try to make rudimentary like drawing programs uh in q basic like oh i'm gonna make pac-man and i would try to like make the little circle mouth open and close by sort of trying to figure out like oh i found some code for drawing a circle cool now i can like translate the circle like how do i open the circle to like have the mouth like chomp and i didn't know about sprites or like like so i would like try to find little math equations that would draw it on the board in various ways and so i would start with that kind of stuff um and then also eventually
不想回家和我的孩子一起做这个，你知道的，就像我不能责怪他一样，所以我们没有连续做几个小时，但我会尝试在 Q Basic 中制作一些初级的绘图程序，呃，就像“哦，我要做一个吃豆人”，我会试着让那个小圆圈嘴巴张开和闭上，通过试图弄清楚，比如“哦，我找到了一些画圆的代码，太酷了，现在我可以像平移圆一样了，我怎么才能把圆打开，让嘴巴像是在咀嚼呢？”我不知道什么是精灵，或者说……所以我会试着在黑板上用各种方法画出它的数学方程，我会从那种东西开始，嗯，然后最终
like when i was in i guess high school i learned c that would have been like 10th and 11th grade but when i was in middle school mostly like goofing around like on q basic and trying stuff in that getting it to you know print funny messages out make little goofy things and in middle school actually on my calculator like i would always program i guess it was some form of basic on the calculator oh yeah ti basic yeah okay yeah yeah okay so i like ti basic and i would do um like wrote like a little rpg for myself where i would like you know randomly choose a number and attack monsters and if you success you would get gold and if you like got attacked no way i did exactly the same thing
比如当我在，我猜是高中时，我学了 C 语言，大概是在高一高二的时候，但当我在初中时，大部分时间都是在 Q Basic 上瞎胡闹，在上面尝试各种东西，让它，你知道的，打印出搞笑的信息，做一些傻乎乎的小东西，而在初中时，实际上在我的计算器上，我总是编程，我猜那是计算器上某种形式的 Basic，哦对，TI Basic，对，没错，对，好，对……所以我喜欢 TI Basic，我会做……比如为自己写了一个小 RPG，我会……你知道，随机选择一个数字来攻击怪物，如果你成功了，你就会得到金币，如果你被攻击了……不会吧，我做了完全一样的事情。
i think the like text-based adventure is like just interesting enough without running into like becoming too complicated too fast where you have spaghetti code and you can't manage the sort of game state and so i think it makes a lot of sense and so yeah i would program then the if you beat the final i think there was like 10 bad guys it would draw little animated fireworks on the screen by drawing random lane set line segments and connecting them nice that's awesome yeah i mean i i have a somewhat similar story like um you know as i said my my parents weren't like software engineers or anything like that so they couldn't really there wasn't really any resources like that but i did get a uh
我认为这种基于文本的冒险游戏，恰到好处地有趣，又不会变得太复杂太快，导致出现面条代码、无法管理游戏状态的情况，所以我觉得这非常合理。所以，是的，然后我会编写代码，如果你击败了最终的……我想大约有 10 个坏人，它就会在屏幕上通过绘制随机线段并将它们连接起来，画出小型动态烟花，太棒了，这真厉害。是的，我的意思是，我的经历也差不多，正如我所说，我的父母不是软件工程师或类似的人，所以他们真的……没有那种资源，但我确实得到了一个……
i got an atari 800 and it came with this program called delta drawing that was basically turtle graphics so you have a little arrow and you could you know draw forward you could turn right turn left and it kind of taught me about like egocentric um you know movement and all of that and uh the delta drawing book had a bunch of recipes so i would just punch in like literally what it said and hit go and then i'd get a car or something like that it's amazing drawing that like i could never make by myself but if i just follow the recipe you know it would make a car and then also like when you messed up in the recipe you know you'd get like a car but the wheel would be just totally in the wrong place and so you could kind of look and see
我得到了一台 Atari 800，它自带一个叫做 Delta Drawing 的程序，基本上就是海龟图形学，所以你有一个小箭头，你可以，你知道，向前画，可以向右转、向左转，它在某种程度上教会了我关于自我中心主义的……你知道，运动以及所有这些。Delta Drawing 的书里有一堆食谱，所以我就会照着上面写的输入，然后按回车，接着我就能得到一辆汽车或类似的东西。这太神奇了，画出了那种我靠自己绝对做不出来的东西，但如果我只是按照食谱来做，你知道，它就能造出一辆汽车。而且，当你在食谱中出错时，你知道，你做出来的会像是一辆车，但车轮的位置完全错了，所以你就可以观察并看出……
oh this is what i did wrong and this is how it affected the car you know um so yeah i kind of uh got really into delta drawing and uh doing a lot of that um yeah my aunt was was a software engineer and she got me a computer and uh kind of walked me through basic and things like that i ended up i don't think i did too much with basic um oh i made a i made a game that my cousins and i played where um it was called arm wrestling and basically you had to hit the space bar so many times per second or maybe it was per 10 seconds or something and every time you passed that threshold so every 10 seconds you pass the threshold, you started winning. And if you won three in a row, then you won the arm wrestling. And we broke the space bar on the keyboard.
哦，这就是我做错的地方，这就是它对汽车的影响，你知道……所以，是的，我有点……非常迷恋 Delta Drawing，并做了很多这方面的事情……是的，我阿姨是个软件工程师，她给我买了一台电脑，带我了解了 Basic 之类的一些东西。最后我发现，我对 Basic 似乎没有做太多事情……哦，我和表兄弟们玩过一个游戏，叫做“扳手腕”，基本上你必须每秒按很多次空格键，或者可能是每 10 秒按一次什么的，每次你超过那个阈值，也就是每 10 秒你通过阈值，你就开始获胜。如果你连赢三场，你就赢了扳手腕。我们把键盘上的空格键都按坏了。
That's pretty cool. Yeah, and this was back like, you know, at the Atari where the keyboard was like, basically you couldn't detach it or anything. So we basically broke the atari with that game um and uh uh you know i ended up not being that big a deal but it was kind of goofy but yeah i actually didn't get into coding until much much later um so yeah around like mid high school that's when uh i took a course i took the computer science course and they taught us um c but uh yeah there was a huge gap where I wasn't really doing any coding, but I was always really into board games. And just, yeah, I just played a ton of board games and did a lot of reading, you know,
这真的很酷。是的，那是……你知道，在 Atari 时代，键盘基本上是不能拆卸的什么的。所以我们基本上用那个游戏把 Atari 给玩坏了。嗯，呃，你知道的，最后这也没什么大不了的，但挺滑稽的。不过，是的，我实际上直到很晚很晚才开始接触编程……所以，大概是在高中中期左右，那时我上了一门课，上了一门计算机科学课，他们教我们 C 语言。但是，是的，有一个很长的空白期，我其实没有做任何编程，但我一直非常喜欢桌游。然后，是的，我只是玩了大量的桌游，读了大量的书，你知道……
like not reading, but like puzzle books and things like that. Yeah, I mean, I feel like at least between us, it's pretty similar. And I actually think that's a common thing, which is there's a certain maturity of certain amount of breadth of skills you need to have before you can sit down and write. We've talked about this on the program, but like write computers. So like write computer programs. So if you say, I want to build a 3D graphics game, well, you're going to have to know like enough trigonometry and geometry to be able to do like 3d computation that's pretty high bar actually yeah and so like that's really tough
不是那种阅读，而是解谜书之类的东西。是的，我的意思是，我觉得至少在我们之间，这挺相似的。而且我实际上认为这是一个很普遍的现象，那就是在你坐下来编写之前，你需要具备一定成熟度的大量技能。我们在节目中讨论过这个，就像编写计算机一样。所以，就像编写计算机程序一样。如果你说，我想做一个 3D 图形游戏，好吧，你得懂足够的三角学和几何学才能进行 3D 计算，这其实是个挺高的门槛。是的，这真的很难。
but having a kid be introduced to like late elementary middle school so i guess for people not in the states i'd be like you know 10 years old i think you can start to introduce kids into like what loops are and printing your name but i don't think they're going to engage at the level of building large amounts of software because i think it just takes focus now of course it could be an exception where like you probably don't need any help and you become like a contributor to linux kernel at like 10 sure yeah there's always like savants yeah but i mean i think for the most part, like teaching a kid to code, I think is about keeping them in that mindset of like, like Jason was pointing out,
但让小孩子在小学高年级或初中接触这些，所以对于不在美国的人来说，大概就是 10 岁左右，我认为你可以开始向孩子们介绍什么是循环以及打印你的名字，但我不认为他们会达到构建大量软件的参与度，因为我认为这需要专注力。当然，可能会有例外，就像你可能不需要任何帮助，在 10 岁左右就成为了 Linux 内核的贡献者一样，当然，总会有这种天才。但我的意思是，我认为对于大多数人来说，教孩子写代码，其实是为了让他们保持那种心态，就像杰森指出的那样……
breaking it, but trying to understand why it broke. If you just succeed by randomly trying, I don't find that that doesn't seem like a good way to kind of progress. So now it's not that there aren't times when it's called for just like trying random things until it works like i know there's an off by one error here somewhere um but for the most part thinking through the code and anticipating what it's going to do seems to benefit me more and i think as jason was pointing out those are skills you learn by playing board games by you know doing uh you know scientific pursuits and activities and even the scientific method to some extent, right? Like predicting what's going to happen, trying to say, how would I test
打破它，但试图理解它为什么会坏。如果你只是通过随机尝试来成功，我不觉得……这似乎不是一种取得进展的好方法。所以，现在并不是说没有需要“随便试错直到它起作用”的时候——我知道这里某个地方有一个“差一错误”——但总的来说，思考代码并预测它会做什么似乎对我有更多帮助。而且我认为，正如杰森所指出的，这些技能是通过玩桌游、通过进行科学追求和活动、甚至在某种程度上通过科学方法学到的，对吧？比如预测将要发生的事情，试着去说，我该如何测试
whether this is true or not? I think having those kinds of approaches are actually enormously beneficial. And so when you say, you know, kind of teaching kids to program or teaching kids to code, I actually think it's about not so much what language do you teach them, but about these kind of underlying concepts. Getting into intricacies of a type system is probably not super engaging to a nine-year-old. Yeah, right. Yeah, I mean, I think another sort of like line to walk, one thing where it gets kind of difficult is you want to to sort of help but then you can't help too much yes so it's like like yeah like sometimes you know uh we had this this uh this game where you just uh build train tracks and then you could put a train down the train goes on the tracks and uh it's it's
这是否属实？我认为拥有这些方法实际上是非常有益的。所以当你谈到，你知道，教孩子们编程或教孩子们写代码时，我实际上认为，这与其说你要教他们什么语言，不如说关乎这些底层的概念。去深入了解类型系统的错综复杂，对于一个九岁的孩子来说可能不是很有吸引力。是的，对吧。是的，我的意思是，我认为另一个需要把握的平衡点，一个变得有点困难的地方是，你想要去提供帮助，但你又不能帮得太多。是的，所以就像……有时候，你知道，我们有这样一个游戏，你只需要建造铁路线，然后你就可以放一列火车在上面，火车就会在轨道上行驶，这很……
it's a simple idea it's just like you're dragging tracks and you're laying them down on these tiles. But the thing is the tracks have to sort of line up, right? So, I mean, if you have, like, if you wanted to, if you had a train that was going, or a track that was going, let's say, west to east, you couldn't just put a track that's going south to north. Like, you have to have one of the curvy tracks. Like, it has to be contiguous, right?
这是一个简单的想法，就像你把轨道拖动并铺设在这些瓷砖上一样。但问题是，轨道必须对齐，对吧？所以，我的意思是，如果你有一列正在行驶的火车，或者一条正在延伸的轨道，比方说从西向东，你不能只放一条从南向北的轨道。就像，你必须使用其中一条弯曲的轨道。就像，它必须是连在一起的，对吧？
And we got this game, game like about a year or two ago and so even my son was maybe like three and he just found it really frustrating and you know if i just left it like to do it he just would have given up but i stayed with him and like you know i made the tracks and things like that and so he couldn't really make any mistakes um because i felt like it was just it was just too far advanced um but then now he just does it on his own totally so it's like it's really hard to sort of strike that balance between like you want them to make mistakes but then you want you don't want them to like lose interest either or get really frustrated or whatever that's i think with
我们大概在一两年前买了这款游戏，所以即使我儿子大概三岁时，他也觉得这非常令人沮丧。你知道，如果我任由他自己去做，他早就放弃了。但我陪着他，你知道，我来铺轨道之类的，这样他就不会犯什么错误了，因为我觉得这对他来说实在太超前了。但现在他完全可以自己独立完成了，所以，很难在“你想让他们犯错”和“你又不想让他们失去兴趣或变得非常沮丧”之间找到平衡。我认为，对于……
kids especially it's like a very difficult line to walk. But yeah, I mean, well, that's, I think that's true probably for anything, but especially something like coding. If you want to get them to something kind of like that's pretty advanced, it's really hard to have sort of those stepping stones. So if you have a kid who you think is ready
特别是对孩子们来说，这是一条很难把握的界限。但是，是的，我的意思是，嗯，我想这对于任何事情来说大概都是真的，但对于像编程这样特别是这样。如果你想让他们接触到某种相当高级的东西，要拥有这些阶梯式的过渡真的很难。所以如果你有一个你认为已经准备好的孩子
to actually learn a programming language and sit at a computer and type, what would you do what language would you use would you do a web something would you do python non-web like interactive like both of you and i described something that was i mean we're maybe a little predating the web um but this sort of interactive console graphics getting used to how to deal with that not console graphics but just like a text input and back and forth um i mean do you think that's the way to go no i mean so i actually now that i remember you know i totally forgotten about this until just now but there was something i think it was called like hyper text or something like that but basically it was meant for presentations think of it as like basically powerpoint but
去真正学习一门编程语言并坐在电脑前打字，你会怎么做？你会用什么语言？你会做网络方面的吗？还是非网络的交互式？——你们俩和我描述的东西，我的意思是，我们可能比 Web 出现得稍微早一点，但这种交互式的控制台图形，习惯于如何处理这些……不是控制台图形，而只是一种文本输入和来回交互。我的意思是，你认为这是应该走的路吗？不，我的意思是，我现在想起来了，你知道，直到刚才我完全把它给忘了，但曾经有一种东西，我记不清是不是叫超文本之类的，但基本上它是用于演示的，你可以把它想象成基本上是 PowerPoint，但是
there was sort of logic so like in powerpoint you know you can have animations you press the button and you know you go to the next slide but it actually just slides in some text and things like that so this was like you know it was actually meant for giving really interesting kind of kiosk type presentations, like interactive presentations. And so it had some very basic branching and things like that. But the nice thing about it was it was all graphical. I mean, think of like just PowerPoint. You're not writing any code or anything.
里面有一些逻辑，比如在 PowerPoint 中，你知道你可以有动画，你按一个按钮，然后你知道，你进入下一张幻灯片，但它实际上只是滑动进入一些文本之类的内容。所以这就像是……它实际上是用来做非常有趣的那种亭子式演示的，就像交互式演示一样。所以它有一些非常基础的分支之类的内容。但它的好处在于它是全图形化的。我的意思是，想想就像 PowerPoint 一样。你不需要写任何代码或做类似的事情。
And so I think something like that. So we actually have something called a Kodi, K-O-D-I, and it has this graphical programming language where you just kind of drag and drop little modules and stitch them together. I feel like that's probably the best way to start. I probably wouldn't start by typing on the keyboard, especially nowadays with iPads and all of that. Sure. So I've tried these, like, there's some coding games, and I've had my kids play those on the iPad where you, you know, tell a person, right, right, jump, right. You know, and those trick pretty good. And I know Apple made these Swift playgrounds,
所以我想类似这样的东西。因此，我们实际上有一种叫做 Kodi 的东西，K-O-D-I，它有一种图形化编程语言，你只需拖放一些小模块并将它们拼接在一起。我觉得这可能是最好的开始方式。我可能不会从在键盘上打字开始，尤其是现在有了 iPad 和所有这些设备之后。当然。所以我也尝试过这些，比如有一些编程游戏，我曾让我的孩子们在 iPad 上玩那些，你在那里，你知道，告诉一个人，向右，向右，跳跃，向右。你知道，那些效果挺不错的。而且我知道苹果公司推出了这些 Swift Playgrounds，
which I tried. I thought they were kind of interesting. Um, but there's still a little premature kids, but I think that's a, those seem really well done. And I think actually like as goofy as it sounds, having something where there's graphical interaction and also like good documentation. So it's well thought through what's supposed to happen because a lot of times when I would do examples or coding questions, there's enough ambiguity where there's frustration
我试过。我觉得它们挺有趣的。嗯，但对孩子们来说还是有点太早了，不过我认为这些……这些看起来做得非常好。而且我认为实际上，听起来虽然有点傻，但拥有某种既有图形交互又有良好文档的东西。所以它的预期效果是经过深思熟虑的，因为很多时候当我做示例或编码问题时，会有足够的模糊性，从而导致对于如何继续前进产生挫败感。
about what you're supposed to do to progress forward. Yep, yeah. I played one, my son and I played one on the iPad called Codable. And basically you're this little fuzzball. And it's basically like turtle graphics. So you say, you know, go right, go up, go right, go up. You have to kind of plan it all in advance.
关于你应该做什么才能取得进展。是的，没错。我玩过一个，我和我儿子在 iPad 上玩过一个叫 Codable 的游戏。基本上你是个小绒球。它基本上就像海龟图形学。所以你会说，你知道，向右走，向上走，向右走，向上走。你必须提前把这一切都规划好。
And then when you hit go, it executes that. And then you can kind of see like, oh, shoot, you know, I wasn't supposed to go up twice or whatever. But yeah, I think those games are really where it's at. I would probably stay away from, asrick said like you know as soon as you get into real coding you have to do a lot of reading and um even if you're you know even once you know our kids could read you know at adult level and all that it's still pretty taxing you know until you become a teenager it's probably pretty exhausting to read because you have to really think hard about it. It's not like as unconscious as it is for an adult. And so a lot of these graphical things are really the way to go.
然后当你点击开始时，它就会执行。然后你就可以看到，哦，糟了，你知道，我不应该向上走两次，或者诸如此类的话。但是，是的，我认为这些游戏才是真正的王道。我可能会远离……正如埃里克所说，你知道，一旦你进入真正的编程，你必须进行大量的阅读，并且……即使你是，你知道，即使我们的孩子能以成人的水平阅读以及所有这些，这仍然相当费劲，你知道，直到你成为青少年之前，阅读可能都相当令人筋疲力尽，因为你必须对它进行深入的思考。它不像成年人那样无意识。所以很多这样的图形化东西确实是正确的发展方向。
But I guess like the high level here is just to like get kids into logic. So there's these board games um you know that teach like strategy and all of that um there's these apps there's visual programming languages and they all kind of teach the basics around sort of logic around understanding sort of cause and effect you know like did you lose three times in a row just randomness like if you're playing chutes and ladders and you lose, you can't really say, oh, I wish I could have done things differently. But even just knowing and understanding that the game is just complete random,
但我想这里的高级理念只是让孩子们接触逻辑。所以有一些桌游，你知道，它们教授策略以及所有这些，还有这些应用程序，有可视化编程语言，它们都在某种程度上教授围绕逻辑的基础知识，围绕理解因果关系，你知道，就像你是连续三次输掉只是因为随机性吗？如果你在玩《蛇梯棋》然后你输了，你真的不能说，哦，我希望我能用不同的方式做事。但即使只是知道并理解这个游戏完全是随机的，
that by in and of itself is a good lesson. Like, just understanding that you're following this process, but you have no control. It's really just about understanding the game versus, you know, you're following this process, but you have no control. It's really just about understanding the game versus, you know, I don't know, Monopoly or something where you have a lot of controls, a lot of things you can do and the things you do matter. I think that getting kids to understand that is really important. That makes sense. Yeah, I guess this wasn't so much a like strict curriculum on how to teach kids to code, but I'm not sure that one exists. Yeah, I mean, honestly, you know, and where we live, you know, we've talked about this,
光是这一点本身就是一个好教训。就像，只要明白你在遵循这个过程，但你没有任何控制权。这真的只是关于理解游戏，而不是，你知道，我不知道，比如《大富翁》或其他有很多控制、有很多你可以做的事情并且你所做的事情很重要游戏。我认为让孩子们理解这一点非常重要。这说得通。是的，我想这与其说是一个关于如何教孩子写代码的严格课程，不如说我不确定是否存在这样一套课程。是的，我的意思是，老实说，你知道，我们居住的地方，你知道，我们讨论过这个，
Patrick and I live in the Valley and, um, you know, the, the, the, I don't know about you, but, but we have so many of these coding camps in my neighborhood. Um, there's literally eight coding camps on this one street. So if I go, you know, a couple of blocks from my house, uh, it puts me on this, this pretty main road and there's eight coding camps. And, uh, I just don't, yeah, I think that's not the way to go. I mean, I think it's, it's one of these things that, uh, it's fair. It's a deceptive goal. Like if you start marching towards the goal, I don't think you actually get there. I think actually you could sort of stint it, stint the growth. I feel like the coding really comes like after someone has already
帕特里克和我住在山谷里，而且，你知道，我不知道你怎么样，但在我的邻里有这么多这样的编程训练营。在这条街上 literalmente 有八个编程训练营。所以如果我走，你知道，离我家几个街区，它就把我带到了这条相当主要的主干道上，那里有八个编程训练营。而且，我只是觉得，是的，我认为这不是正确的方法。我的意思是，我认为这是那种……这是一个具有欺骗性的目标。如果你开始朝着这个目标进发，我认为你实际上并不会到达那里。我认为实际上你可能会阻碍，阻碍成长。我觉得编程真的要在一个人已经
understood a lot more fundamental stuff. And of course, there's always savants who made their first app when they're 12 years old and things like that. But I think in general, like, you know, jumping straight into Python or something like that might actually distract from the overall goal, which is really to build a foundation in like logic and causality. I think I agree.
理解了更多基础的东西之后才会到来。当然，总会有一些在 12 岁时就制作了他们的第一个应用程序的天才之类的。但我认为总的来说，你知道，直接跳进 Python 或类似的东西可能会分散整体的目标，也就是真正在逻辑和因果关系方面建立一个基础。我想我同意。
Yeah, so if anyone has any cool resources, so just to recap real quick, you know, I think board games are really solid. I think there's a bunch of really cool apps. There's all sorts of visual programming languages. Just to list a few, I mean, there's Scratch, there's Logo. There's an app called Scratch Junior, which is like a limited version of Scratch. But, you know, you can find it.
是的，所以如果任何人有什么很酷的资源，为了快速回顾一下，你知道，我认为桌游真的很扎实。我认为有一堆非常酷的应用程序。有各种各样的可视化编程语言。仅举几例，我的意思是，有 Scratch，有 Logo。有一个叫做 Scratch Junior 的应用程序，它就像是 Scratch 的精简版。但是，你知道，你可以找到它。
If you look up visual programming languages for kids, you'll find a ton of these in every possible conceivable OS. And then, you know, you want to balance between being frustrated and, you know, just giving away all the answers, right? So as a parent, that's a challenge. As a guardian, that's a challenge. But yeah, I think that's basically the high level of it. And don't just, you know, hand a five-year-old a c-book because that's not gonna work well maybe do it one time to see if you have a savant and then yeah then don't yeah i mean if they ask you if they say hey you know this is pretty cool but i really want to learn assembly well then you know go for it yeah oh the other thing actually just just one other thing i thought
如果你查找适合儿童的可视化编程语言，你会在每个可能想到的操作系统上找到大量这样的语言。然后，你知道，你想要在感到沮丧和直接给出所有答案之间取得平衡，对吧？所以作为父母，这是一个挑战。作为监护人，这是一个挑战。但是，是的，我想这基本上就是它的宏观层面。不要只是，你知道，把一本 C 语言书塞给一个五岁的孩子，因为那不会管用。好吧，也许可以试一次，看看你是不是有个天才，然后，是的，那就别再试了。是的，我的意思是，如果他们问你，如果他们说“嘿，你知道，这挺酷的，但我真的很想学汇编”，那你知道，放手去做吧。哦，另外一件事，实际上，我刚刚想到的另一件事
of is you know i've been doing and i think you also fit this category, we do a lot of robotics stuff. And in general, if you do anything related to coding or anything related to, I don't know, building anything, yeah, just find a way to get your kids involved. robotics things and you know my son's doesn't have the attention span for it but what i did is uh i got a buddy of mine to do it too and so when there's two of us and two kids then it's like you know the kids can kind of chase each other a bit or you know when they do pay attention we're there um and or we could take turns like i can keep the two kids from you know stepping on nails while you know my friend uh does some work on the robot and I can switch. So that also worked out pretty well. But, yeah, did your dad ever get you involved in any of his side projects or anything like that? So my dad never really had side projects like that.
是，你知道，我一直在做，而且我想你也符合这个类别，我们做了很多机器人相关的事情。总的来说，如果你做任何与编程相关的事情，或者任何与，我不知道，构建任何东西相关的事情，是的，只要找个方法让你的孩子们参与进来。机器人相关的事情，你知道，我儿子的注意力维持不了那么久，但我所做的是，我找了一个好朋友也一起做，所以当我们有两个人和两个孩子时，就像，你知道，孩子们可以互相追逐一会儿，或者当他们真的注意到时，我们在那里，或者我们可以轮流，我可以阻止这两个孩子踩到钉子，而我的朋友可以对机器人做一些工作，然后我再换。所以这也挺管用的。但是，是的，你爸爸曾经让你参与过他的任何副业或类似的事情吗？所以我的爸爸从来没有过那种副业。
But I mean, when we would do a science fair each year or whatever, I don't know if that's at all the thing. But we would have to do a science project and he would always get involved with us and doing those experiments and helping us and yeah i guess we did do stuff sometimes yeah yeah my dad you know did a lot of he's a mechanical you know engineer so he did a lot of mechanical stuff and uh he'd always have me like help him like set up pulleys and stuff like that in the house wait set up pulleys in the house that sounds yeah i mean in the garage in the But yeah, he literally had this whole pulley system. And yeah, it's pretty wild. I mean, he would be able to pull like boats.
但是，我的意思是，当我们每年做一个科学博览会或类似的事情时，我不知道这是否算是一回事。但我们必须做一个科学项目，他总是会参与进来，和我们一起做那些实验并帮助我们……是的，我想我们有时确实会做一些事情。是的，我爸爸做了很多……他是一个机械工程师，所以他做了很多机械方面的事情，他总是让我帮忙，比如在家里安装滑轮之类的。等等，在家里安装滑轮？听起来……是的，我的意思是，在车库里。但是，是的，他真的有整套滑轮系统。而且，是的，这太疯狂了。我的意思是，他能够拉动船只。
He had boats like just attached to the roof of the ceiling of the garage. So like you would just park the car under a huge boat. And there was this like crazy pulley system system which gives you all this mechanical advantage but you have to turn a winch like a hundred times to get this boat to go up you know four feet so he just had all these crazy things that sounds pretty cool actually do you have pictures it seems like you guys have pictures yeah i gotta send you uh a picture of my dad's garage i'll ask him to take a picture we could put it on the blog yeah give me famous internet famous internet points that's right cool catch you later the intro music is axo by biner pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons
他把船只直接挂在车库天花板的屋顶上。所以你只要把车停在一艘巨大的船下面。那里有一个疯狂的滑轮系统，它给你提供了所有的机械优势，但你必须转动绞盘一百次才能让那艘船上升四英尺，所以他只是有所有这些疯狂的东西。听起来其实挺酷的，你有照片吗？感觉你们有照片。是的，我得给你发一张我爸爸车库的照片，我会请他拍张照片，我们可以把它放在博客上。耶，给我著名的互联网点数。没错。回头见。片头曲是 Biner Pilot 创作的《Axo》。Programming Throwdown 由 Creative Commons 发布
attribution share alike 2.0 license you're're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可协议。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，改编、演绎作品，但您必须对帕特里克和我进行署名，并以相同方式共享。这个剧集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。